Richmond Virginia is Ashton calling hey
Ashton how are you
goodness offer better than I deserve
what's up so I just recently got laid
off from my job bug this is really good
money and I took a job where I'm not
making good money at all basically I was
- I'm under qualified for the job that
I'm in right now so I'm taking quite a
huge pay cut with a lot of debt okay
you're under qualified for the job
you're in that pays a lot less or
overqualified I'm under qualified okay
so you don't know how to do the job
you're in it requires a degree and I'm
20 okay and it pays a lot less than you
used to make correct okay what did you
used to do I was a marketing agent for a
pharmacy okay and you made what kind of
money take-home was about 130,000 Wow
at 20 years old you're rockin it man
pretty amazing used to be so what
happened to that job my boss the
pharmacist is facing a 17 felony counts
of drug trafficking hmm so he was
marketing the wrong stuff okay oh my
gosh okay so he paid you to do what what
kind of a deal what were you doing so
there's a lot of medications that
reimburse much higher so for instance
you have a lot of pain you might take
naproxen if you take a specific dose of
that instead of making about $5 we'd
make about $1,300 and I would just get
those physicians to get on board with
switching the lower to the higher paying
one okay and that kind so you were
calling on physicians changing the
dosage legally I assume what you were
doing was legal but he got caught for
doing other stuff right yeah he was
selling narcotics without prescriptions
yeah does the does the do other
pharmacists not do what he does then
I've never heard of this this is
interesting so it's all independent
pharmacies independent pharmacies try
their best to find these higher imaging
drugs
and then you will attempt to change them
we kinda just headed down to a science
okay so why can you not go knock on the
door of an independent pharmacy and show
them what you could do for them I have
there's only a few in my area and all of
them kind of turned off about the reason
why he was fired I got one job offer but
it wasn't me it was making about five
thousand dollars more than I'm making
now and I have I just had to do for him
and I need insurance he was a world to
provide that mm-hmm
five thousand dollars will buy you
insurance okay you could have bought
insurance and stayed in the same career
field what are you doing now
I'm a marketing agent for a home health
care agency okay all right here's the
thing you you have the ability to get
your hand around what a value
proposition looks like and how to sell
it to people and how to go through the
rejection to get it sold to people and
develop the relationships to get it sold
to people that is a high-paying skill
that you have selling is one of the
highest paid professions in America and
what you're doing what you've learned
how to do whether you realize that or
not was selling and so on you know I
don't know what it is you're going to
sell but you need to find something that
you can sell and you've obviously
developed you've fallen into probably
somewhat accidentally a career field
here that's very niche but you know how
to call on physicians and get them to do
things and so the medical device
business the pharmaceutical business
working for a drug company selling
pharmaceuticals is you know those guys
make good money both of those guys make
good money in the sales world and so you
might be standing over the shoulder of a
surgeon where they're inserting an
apparatus into a patient that you sold
to them and you assist in that whole
process that's the medical device sales
people and several of those guys and
gals that I know make a couple of
hundred a year now they're not twenty
years old they developed a career over
time but I think you've got the skill
set to go into the pharma pharmaceutical
world or the medical device world and
those are the places I would be
looking if I were you jump on the Ken
Coleman show dot-com and read everything
that Ken has got there and download his
resume builder and download his process
for tracking and getting into a position
at a new job I think you've been
spiraling and falling backward because
you were attached to an embarrassing
situation that embarrassed you even
though it wasn't your fault and it kind
of stains you a little bit even though
it wasn't your fault because that's why
those other people are turning you away
but if you truly had no knowledge of all
that other stuff you're very employable
in these other areas and you just got a
little bit scared because you got
knocked down and you got a new baby and
you're 20 and you're just getting
started in life I'm here to tell you as
your coach you're better than you feel
like you are right now you've got some
serious skills young man
let's repackage them and go back at this
job market again I think you can make a
lot more than you're making now it may
take you a little time to get it all
done and you may need to come into
something the entry level where you have
chance to prove yourself but do you know
how to do this you can prove yourself
so the Ken Coleman show dot-com that's
the website to go to the Ken Coleman
show dot-com
[Music]